[Musique]
mes seins nus à sans filtre le podcast
on parle de ce qu'on veut que nos
invités dati site super content avec moi
d'hommes plante on est en direct de nos
nouveaux studios on vous donne un petit
sneak peek de ce qui s'en vient mais
juste pour les trous parce qu'après ça
on retourne chez nous pour le podcast de
cette semaine avec avec ses finalistes
qui comédienne que vous connaissez
sûrement qui est une vedette de nos
écrans québécois mais aussi des écrans
internationale en fait on le découvre en
2011 dans le film monsieur lazhar alors
qu'ils étaient encore tout petit le
enfin après cela volume de livres en
2013 après les rôles se sont succédé il
ya un film à nouveau film d'action et
s'appelle claude klose ou closer et
louis sont explique ce club à qui vous
pouvez trouver le facilement d'autres
films s'en viennent dont un film de
requins incroyable
finaliste qui est tellement jeune que
justin qui vient d'avoir 19 ans mais qui
a une feuille de route assez
impressionnante merci soit belle
conversation sur sa carrière son
parcours sur son métier d'acteur c'est
son plan d'affaires c'est pas la fin
ouais donc écouter sur les spurs et les
messins sinon vous pouvez nous
encourager sur petrov et tué l'ont fait
on essaie de faire le plus souvent
possible des des podcasts exclusive du
contenu exclusif vous même poser des
questions aux invités comme c'est arrivé
sur ce podcast ci avec sa fille on
apprend qu'une question de nos membres
pétrole vous allez voir
ensuite vous nous écoutez présentement
sur youtube si vous ne vous voyez où sur
balade dos lâche pas de faille si vous
nous écoutez seulement c'est toujours
apprécié le laisser en commentaire de
nous donner une note de 5 étoiles sur
balles à dos de vous abonner à notre
chaîne que ce soit sur youtube ou sur
balles à dos toutes ces plateformes le
suivi nous en font partager la bonne
nouvelle est allé en paix sur ce final
magistral bon podcast bon aiguë
[Musique]
tel est parti à l'eau mais vous oui
merci d'être ici qu'on veut oui bon
c'est un écrivain
ouais j'en passe
en fait je pense que souvent j'utilise
les faits pour comme quand celle du
japon que je me faisais quand j'étais
réellement il est écrit que tu comme des
élections ça aussi c est pas grave
non mais ça comme les agents peu mes
amis mais comme déjà que je peut
notamment voir comment chaque
commentaire caché mini session au cégep
mais j'ai dû quitter manas baisse est
c'est aussi parce que j'étais comme
parti et pour un bout et que je fais des
cours à distance et qu'un humain
m'arrêter car il m'avouera maison jean
lapointe et netflix genre constamment
même mois hier je texter de la musique
comme la gagne mais ça fait saisi jeu
cette cession si dans le fond c'est
comme un mois parce que j'étais parti en
janvier pendant deux mois j'allais
tourner un film à londres
et puis revenu janvier février
ça fait comme un mois et demi du revenu
comme l'état-nation village là où le tpo
quant à ce qu'il faut et non mais dans
le fond j'ai deux films qui devrait
sortir cette année lui sans vraiment
rapidement parce qu'ils veulent le seul
crime est de règle moi je sais qui est
le sortie pour l'été dans le hockey
parce que le tournoi mais en fait j'ai
fait j'ai fait à trois semaines en
république dominicaine le mois de
décembre puis après ça tout le reste du
film dans le fonds serait en dessous de
l'eau parce que c'est comme des filles
qui vont inviter des grands jardins week
end des grottes souterraines fait tout
ce qui tourne dans un bassin à l'ombre
et qui ont été comme les deux mois de
période que j'ai dans un bassin naturel
qui y mettent
c'est comme un gros bassin se faire
n'importe quoi le i n'ont vraiment pas
été jetée juste et dans l'opus take on
me mettait des m les espèces de plateau
qui configure est comme il fait qu'on
verrait une table il mettait dans le
fond de ce genre des roches et des
statuts c'est c'est tellement dur
expliqué comme c'est plus clair on va
voir le film les césures explique comme
ça mais qui mettait il n'était pas si
pour rendre l'eau un peu comme l'eau de
la mer comme que sa texture est un peu
il mettait du brocoli broyer mené chaud
ça comme ça va mener moussa commencé à
cuire dans l'eau on est vraiment et
plaine du colysée carré janvier plonge
avec des sacs de brûlis qui arrivait le
matin qui projet solar dans une phase
qui jardine l'est comme un peu de
cahiers pour donner sur des comme ça
j'ai fait des gens là dessus parce que
c'est une meule en politique on a
commencé le tournage et on vous dit que
c'était comme ça règle sa voix puis les
deux derniers semaines si beji comment
savoir ce qu'ils ne disent pas ce que je
mange mon médecin tout pigé dit qu'est
ce que je peux faire faire passer dans
l'eau pour deux semaines comme moi et
non ce vraiment une possibilité
j'ai très envie de rester plus longtemps
et c'est pour le match j'avais j'ai un
petit mois j'ai vraiment amusant c'est
comme apprendre pilule à avaler des
pilules et le jt genre 12 ici pilule le
javier genre à l'extrême comme des bébés
des médicaments jambes aux oreilles pas
prêt si j'avais tellement mal avec eux
je prenne des ordres d or des enfants je
pense qu'ils mettaient cela que des
ninjas avec le site est tellement fort
pour chaque bloc les bases le pâtissier
elle et je n'ai pas l'argent
maintenant j'ai su que j'avais mal au
coeur parce que c'était tellement fort
qu'il me donnait déjà entre en jeu j'en
fais coupe avant mal au coeur
sous l'eau les gt est basé le jt comme
seul enfant les falaises respect dans un
espèce de masques à la base sera un peu
genre christophe claustrophobie mais au
moins deux poteaux de lignes à 10 en
dessous nous mettons oui oui c'est un
peu ça oui parce que on passait comme si
vraiment on parle d'un groupe fait
communiquer avec les autres filles dans
le fond mais c'est vraiment écoute c'est
tellement spécial s'est exprimé dans le
fossé se sait qu'on a des masques ou ne
fasse au complet pinon et des micros qui
peuvent mettre qui nous relient aux
autres films ce 6e balle film
ouais ouais c'est dans le phénomène du
dialogue qui fait que ce fait qui ont
comme un speaker en dessous de l'eau
pour qu'on puisse entendre parler mais
si nous on en parle comme l'ip bull
sorte de masque en même temps c'est
qu'il faut qu'on arrête de respirer
quand les autres par pour les entendre
en même temps foutu respecter l'éthique
de ce fait en ligne c'est tellement
bizarre comme concède pilotes souvent t
entends pas fait qu'il faut vraiment que
tu réussisses apprendre des propres
lignes et celle des autres des points
des fois tu t'attendais même pas ce
qu'il disait tu faisais juste assumer
qu'avec soyez plus leur lait bougies
petit et comme je pense qu'elle a fini
avec le stress de ben ali
en fait on était à quatre là en groupe
le plomb ce métier un requin blond se
mettaient à crier c'était quelque chose
ou sinon des fois ce parce qu'il ya des
foyers enlever nos micros justement pour
pâques et comme les fils qui nous
suivent avec le real peut donner des
directives mais pas toi je peux répondre
avec le lui comme il peut et envoie
chier mais génial avec les deux vallées
blague t comme me poser des questions
c'est tellement dc va se poser des
questions de 6,2 soit jean une micro
questions j'en ait eu besoin de choix
plus vers la gauche c'est comme le dit
et essayiste fille qui gomme
allons allons la notion gamescom comme
moi juste la fac-ci vraiment et ouais
c'est fou c'est vrai et seul alphonse et
de discussions 3 comprend une série avec
un des requins qui sont ces gens n'ont
plus jamais c'est vraiment juste belle
enlevant deux premiers qui sont netflix
en ce moment ses deux filles vont faire
du catch diving puis on s'adonne que la
cage tombe au fond de nous que les il
faut qu'il reste à remonter à la surface
mais s'ils sortent de la cage sont dans
la mer peut se protéger il ya des
requins fait qu'ils sont attaqués par
des requins ils ont patiemment plus
intelligent comme ça me blesse parce que
le deuxième film ont aucunement rapports
avec le premier ministre john key j'en
ressors pas d'une cage comme on dit ça
mais je pense qu est ce qu ils font all
i need a vu moi qui l'ait fait on essaie
tout débat donnait comme changer de site
c'est comme sortir autant mais m mais
c'est vrai que ça fait vraiment pas
besoin de voir le premier pour voir le
deuxième je pense que le deuxième étape
c'est même pas pour marcher le premier
parce que j'ai quand même trouvé le
premier hôte mais c'est ça c'est juste
que comme c'est moins répétitif parce
que comme on est vraiment dans des
groupes il ya plus de plateaux que juste
être dans une cage dû renoncer on se
promène le tunnel en tunnel pied la
grosse majorité du film par son soûl moi
et puis pour ceux qui s'y colle original
moi ça me tentait l'alpha huaxi pas jean
rède josuke com qui fait acquis pleut on
ne voit plus c'est vraiment tout fait
péter un 10 minutes connexes à
l'extérieur de l'eau on met tout le film
soul ou psy comme heroes qu'un film de
requins qui a été fait comme ça c'est ce
qui m'intéresse c'est quand je dis prie
g fatigue non c'est un challenge
physique énorme le dinosaure dans un an
nous à chaque jour et puis moi je suis
pas quelqu un trip solo puis faire la
plonge et seacom
on espère des affaires qui en fait la
première fois que je pleure sur un
plateau de tournage depuis vendredi
il faisait juste s'asseoir pour se
mettait à pleurer tellement élégant
épuisé puis en fait si une scène qui m'a
vraiment fait stresser
parce que pour la plupart du temps ne
masque mais à un certain moment dans le
film que moi il faut que je l'enlève
il a fait que quand tu l'enlèves
règlement fallait que j'aille au dessus
du lot
c'était comme si my soul ou le jeu
pouvait pas faire des allers-retours en
haut ou en bas parce que c'est pas mon
pote et oreilles dans le fond avec le
mot plongeante et moi quand j'avais
répété et jt comme dans une espèce de
tels coups que je voyais tout voyez mon
plongeon c'était mon blond gens qui
étaient avec moi sur le jour du tournage
et pull même plongeurs qui était avec
moi parce qu'il lui était comme à
l'extérieur de l'eau pour le diraison
puis jetée comme ils m'ont placé dans un
espèce de trou noir je vois c'est pas
dit vrai rush mais comme reste que même
famille les ménages un trou noir tu
m'enlèves mon masque mal un bon air le
chant c'est comme essayer de me débattre
sortait quand je vois rien qui de
redemander pour l'heure si je fais pas
juste non à la surface allégerait cela
mais si cantat pudeur le saisit comme le
signale mais comme ses promoteurs comme
quatre secondes arrimer leurs cartes 50
pilotes se voit pop soit juste comme il
tellement fou que je sais mais mais
comme la preuve soit gelée fait j'ai
tellement fait de l'anxiété qui comme
c'est drôle parce que c'est en fait ce
qu'il ressent ce n'était pas en contrôle
ne pas décider quand on en arrive se
poser
tu montes à la surface fait que ce fait
leur être totalement pont contrôle
c'est plus fort que moi puis même si
chez comme sous pas l'avoir ton amant
genre 4 secondes
on dirait que c'est plus fort que moi je
me mettais à faire dans ces types comme
je sentais que j'avais vieille pudeur
qui imprime coupe deux fois le que je
sortais puis comme gage et j'ai failli
dire que mettais ma double enjeu serait
pas capable finalement lire pratique des
principes et je les ai eus fake
même si c'est un film de reykjavik un
rôle de composition c'est pareil je vais
gagner les prix pour ça
reste que c'est un héros look g est il
plus fier par après parce que je comme
j'ai réellement surmonter une partie
surmonté de couacs et comme je n'aurais
jamais pensé faire c'est fou ça c'est
fou ce que tu penses que mais en fait
j'imagine que ce genre de l'expérience
là ça va ça reste longtemps pour toile
et il y aura plus un plateau qui ne doit
pas bloquer le pont soit 70 de parts
cheval dans cette foule déjà que chacun
sait parler y en a pour qui justement la
plongée ils feraient jamais su tandis
que moi tu me demande de faire 10 avec
des araignées déjà mais gérard c'est
bien mais on peut vraiment dire que
comme une expérience
la série des années où les derricks un
écho mais avec marines avaient comme le
sec d'effort qu'un parce que c'est comme
dire qu'un plat ce truc là mais j'ai été
une semaine avait trois semaines en
république dominicaine quand on est
vraiment dans la merde j'ai vraiment
pâtes riz pilaf agit pas d réussi à voir
port pour green en mettant dans le
bassin et même si ces requins plastique
que tu réussis genre à admettre dans
dans une situation extrêmement anemasse
est ce si j'avais pu si sexy tellement
non j'avais vraiment une fois que je
pars quand il avait laissé le fait que
porsche avait pas qui était avec lui je
rentrais dans le tunnel qui avait
jusqu'au cap ap mais maintenant on sait
vraiment pas que j'avais plus peur c'est
justement république dominicaine gauche
avec pouvait être le puits un événement
quand je regarde les chocs comme gigi
buffon un peu le défaut d sign
ça fait vraiment plus fort quand tu
regardes que quand tu es dedans parce
que à cause la luminosité puis la
meilleure dans ses films et de les
pressions que les tunnels mesure genre
500 mah le tout l'impression qu'ils sont
venus publics sont minces pics sont
conçus partie et comme un hymne doivent
tellement avoir pu en maîtres arrivent
en bus le tunnel de foix pour faire
comme on tourne à part classé comme
genre 3,4 michael e
c'est quand même assez grand le pti pour
rentrer comme quatre personnes d'une
caméra tout le monde et quand même grand
mère à la caméra ça m'a vraiment plu qui
fait qu on aime acheter
j'étais vraiment fait la magie du cinéma
c'est fou pari c'est valve avec des
prises de vues pied parce que moi
message
j'ai juste le trailer qui ont juste le
trailer ça me donnait froide endommagés
j'ai vraiment peur des requins les films
de requins si de la fois que je déteste
c'est pas que je déteste les regarder
mais je déteste le feeling que ça me
procure
ouais non non je signe mais mais mais
moi je regarde les premiers pieds chaude
parce quelqu'un si jamais un vrai outil
vraiment paul van dyk un passé commun
c'est le quai plastique avec un plongeon
qui n'ont jamais que ça fait un peu
comme après ceux d'hier soir aucun
incident jr oui c'est ça fait moi je
n'ai jamais vu des régals pinos courbe à
fond pour ce rôle là dessus un call
partons agences puis le jardin auditions
pour ce est pas si c'est justement droma
c'était comme une option est vraiment
normal le bain en fait c'est un surfer
parce que c'était pour les états unis
chemin et qui m'a appelé on dit on
aimerait ça tout seul pour se et puis
c'est drôle que j'avais vu premier comme
par coïncidence deux jours avant et j'ai
fait comme qui j'ai aussi un hip hop
c'était comme une scène c'est une scène
finale look et comment on stresse pilon
au manque d'air
mais je demande au boulot on est dans
l'eau mais ils me l'ont juste faire
comme debout en train de parler avec
quelqu'un qui aime moi je suis monsieur
chez nous dans le fond je suis c'est ma
mère qui me lie milling c'est génial a
donné la réplique en forêt
mais comme c'est comme un running gag
parce que maman tellement mauvaise
fournir des lignes c'est comme des fois
c'est vraiment trop dans la peau du
personnage
ça fait tellement rire est tellement
dampierre comme non ukr du comminges
des fois elle oublie comme est pas
capable de le nom est pas capable de
faire ces lignes jusqu'à demain ils
iront dans ta face genre moi j'ai tout à
apprendre par 400 qu'on peut juste à
l'ailé comme dit enfin m6 avec bref j'ai
envoyé élections puisque la partie de ta
mère est coupée au montage vous ôtez
voit soudain une voix s'est tue les
j'avais trouvé ça drôle parce que la
valise c'est comme ça que j'ai le rôle
parce que mon père m'avait approché pour
faire l'option d'installer chez eux et
de la gymnastique
mais j'avais pas voulu auditionné pour
parce que ça ne sentait pas mais mon ami
je n'ai pas fait jeter comme bonjour les
phares se repliaient comme dans la façon
qu'on le tourne c'est comme moi j'ai
fait ma mère elle est derrière la caméra
fait qu'on la voit pas le tonus et comme
le premier sauvetage depuis qu'on l'a
fait comme vraiment ensemble commune
lors des scènes qui est six mois qui
fait que d'autres sont juste tombés là
dessus en fait c'est qui est des fous
mais comme il m'avait appelé moi mais
j'avais dit non
lyon fait j fait comme hey mais j'ai un
ami va peut-être sonné pour le go il lui
avait pas ce qui t'as même agence que
moi avec mon agent m'avait fait parvenir
lui pour le rôle du golfe et moi je t'ai
j'en ai tant que je veux donner sa
réplique ils t'ont dit ouais on ne
voudrait vraiment s'arrêter une
extrêmement bonne comme son premier film
international ouais ouais ouais c'est ça
c'est j'avais pas ses emprunts et fait
main en anglais
j'avais un accent comme j'avais encore
en ce moment quand je parle je pense que
je suis 100% mais
mais c'est se cache dans ses moulages
avant qu'un gros accent québécois mais
ça fonctionnait parce que justement et
la fille avec un accent allemand dans
son suis dit qu'au pour par les kanaks
salma mais séparables qui est jeune on
s'écoute dont ont parlé en anglais comme
un thriller commence le travail et
jusqu'au point depuis avoir accès c'est
vraiment venu naturellement je pense que
c'est à force de faire des entrevues
justement parce qu'après la volaille aux
olives on en est faite comme coucou à
tous les jours j'ai parlé pendant comme
un mois et demi non-stop
puis je pense que si vous juste vraiment
souvenirs là bas je parlais bien anglais
le sait juste que jamais un accent mais
à force de parler pour faire des rôles
et mais même là si en ce moment je met à
parler anglais j'aurais pas d'accent
mais moi je vais en temps un petit
pendant deux semaines pour comme
vraiment m'habituer vu que je parle en
français dans mon quotidien je vais à
l'école en français et je me mets à part
la clique un angle en ce moment moi
j'entends un peu la différence pige pas
comme 100% alors puis mettons 15 24 tous
à commencer par sa conséquence elle a
explosé vraiment pour toi est ce que est
ce qu est la pensée de dire
ok je mets tout le reste sur pause puis
je continue parce que je sais que tu
mets quand même encore l'emphase sur
l'école lot de prix une session of que
tu me dises michel et cohabitant ccsa
message imagine que beaucoup de monde
qui avec des opportunités comme celles
qui sont présentées à thouaré juste dit
ok go en ligne 100% rock le reste mais
c'est sûr qu'ils aient la bonne et comme
la plus grande décision à faire en fait
c'était entre la gymnastique puis ce
n'est pas parce que moi j'étais serait
j'ai entraîné ou cliniques j'étais sûr
comme une équipe sur le générique où
l'équipe des les espoirs olympiques puis
si je m'entraînais 35
ouais ça ça n'a pas de sens c'est paris
qui s'entraîne le plus ingénieuses le
mans j'avais 10 ans et je faisais 30
heures par semaine d'ici oui c'est fou
wes il faut les figurants et paix qui en
14 ans non mais c'est si c'est vraiment
un sujet qui fait je veux ici j'ai dit
je veux tu j'étais blessé aussi à la
base j'ai ici parce que c'est tellement
de cible sur le corps
c est ce que je veux vraiment
m'entraîner pendant encore six ans à ce
que ce soit ma vie pour arriver à 16 ans
pour que ma carrière soit finie que si
c'est pas comme aux états unis que tu es
une bourse piquer ta vie continue et
apprécier fait d aller fixer un énorme
accomplissement personnel pis je pense
que peu importe ce que je vais gagner
avec mon rôle je pense que ça va jamais
aussi puissant que si j'avais réussi à
aller aux jeux olympiques en hausse
quand ça se pourrait que ça fasse la
balle est nominée c'est comique non
d'accord il ya plus de pertinence que
moi je vais que la gymnastique mais
j'étais tellement blessée que j'ai dit
je suis vraiment m'entraîner autant pour
peut-être quelqu'un à 2 face une équipe
ce temps ni le peut-être que je
réussisse à faire l'équipe peut-être que
je me fait pas l'achever gens là il ya
tellement de conséquences parce que
suivront pas et c'est tellement plus
safe puis comme plus sains d'esprit
aussi aiment les cinémas maléfique aime
beaucoup de buts mais c'est ce que j'ai
fait que j'ai décidé d'aller dans le
cinéma petit j'étais blessé aussi fait
que j'étais comme je te plaît à boutte
mais j'admire encore tellement le sport
puis je vais à chaque année ils font
comme des événements est mon club on est
grosse compétition internationale puis
je vais les regarder puis valaisan
projet du bénévolat parce que j'adore
cette je trouve tout temps tellement
impressionnant mais c'est juste je
regarde les filles c'est encore tu seule
envie c'est il parle juste de ce zoo
c'est important d'avoir des amis autre
qui était ami jim popp eu le temps de
sortir tout pas tant d'avoir une vie
d'adolescent normal de feu que moi si
comme dit m emmener sur ce point c'est
beau en même temps mais moi je suis
vraiment contente en fait d'abord et
c'est ce foule à quelle heure je te prie
décision d'arrêter le jeu est vraiment
quand j'ai eu l aval à l'elysée j'avais
commencé et j'ai commencé à 8 ans non
mais là je parle a dit ouais mais sa
motion j'ai commencé à 4 oui si j'arrive
pousse ces foules élèves mais j'ai
toujours eu le respect nous on fait de
natation des noës un énorme respect pour
les sports qui s'entraînait plus la
natation au thon s'entraînait un
sacrement
moi j'ai des amis saf lève tôt le 4 mai
il y avait la gymnastique planeur
synchronisée tele2 sport c'est le plus
de temps à s'entraîner mais je fasse du
massacre et 10 c'est pire je pense
vraiment plus stricts six urgent régime
plus strict je sais pas son plus strict
la gymnastique le plein là je pense
qu'il ya un an chaque roue sans plus
ouais moi j'avais une amie quand vous
êtes dans le même programme de sport
études que moelleux et bill danse par
les soucis 6% en fait que j'ai réussi à
jumeler l'école avec et cinéma d'après
midi offert chaque jour
dépilage depuis la troisième année chez
dans un programme et où tu vas l'école
de comus et à midi les après midi je
retourne chez nous puis comme j'avais
des bonnes notes
la blague comme gérante le 10 sport
études à ce métier reste dans mon
programme mais je m'en fous moi ça me
permettait de faire mes options dali
dans des entrevues l'après midi puis mes
preuves étaient comme obliger justement
de m'envoyer mes travaux dispo comme
masseur je m'en allais des fois si seul
son problème c'est parce que quand
manque l'école les profs sont comme
énoncé 0,6 à l appel à la paix la
possibilité de faire ses examens à
distance parce que moi quand je
participe pour la voleuse livre partie
quatre mois toutes mes profs y avait
comme pas le choix de justement
m'envoyer me truc me voyait
effectivement pour ce que j'ai réussi à
vraiment la beauté des puits en arrêt on
avait vraiment un problème de société si
on empêchait des opportunités comme ce
pour des raisons scolaires oui c'est
parce que le système scolaire dans
l'école et c'est ultra important sauf
que c'est c'est pas la seule et unique
façon d'apprendre qu'un complot lotis
puisqu'ils peuvent faciliter une
opportunité comme celle qui te lui
consentant c'est fou pour tout le monde
doit l'école le monde tantôt ton
entourage le québec au complet
de quoi vraiment une simple c'est cool
tu as pu concilier ce que non mais c'est
comme je suis au cégep en ce moment
justement cinéma chose à tout le temps
drôle quand vraiment la grande majorité
de mes profs sont vraiment son roman
smap ici aussi j'ai donc pu l'obligation
de travail était de voir ce manque
d'écoles qui moi j'ai justement eu la
chance quand je suis parti pour ce film
n'est d'avoir des preuves qui m'ont
vraiment un délit nous envoyer mes
devoirs parce que je me suis un peu pour
moi c'est le j'avais fait ma session la
session mettons de septembre je l'avais
fait au complet
j'ai eu le rôle s'adonnaient qu'il
fallait que je parte pour les trois
dernières semaines mais dis moi j'étais
là tous les jours pendant comme troyes -
le cheval cancellé ma session le même m
fait que la plupart you need is correct
mais je me suis jamais genre un
enseignant en faisait une prof pied elle
voulait vraiment pas mais des gens
jetaient comme et madame si complètement
content parce que je suis en cinéma
[Musique]
dirais que je commence vraiment stupide
qui comme vous ou vivent pas en mesure
demain dès jeudi que j'étudie pour faire
ce qu'elle m'avait littéralement un
tournage quelle meilleure façon
d'apprendre le cinéma que tiana tournage
mais si ce sexisme on fait des mini tôt
que la manche c'est à lui mettre deux
mois des crédits mais j'en apprends
beaucoup de mauvaises yamani c'était
comme étant faire les examens finaux
tous mes projets comprenez que je
tournais oui le pot comme ça excuse moi
l'équipe de 50 personnes je vais sortir
du de l'eau pour aller faire un nom jeu
comme ça marche pas mais elle a profité
comme ce correct fait un examen à
distance par contre faut que ce soit
envoyé à quelle heure faut que ce soit
fait en même temps tous les étudiants
comme madame sur un bateau en plein
milieu de la mer qui fait mal aux
carreaux dalles vrai que l'ipi dans les
cas où la magie commence à écrire des
dissertations man en juillet le plateau
ouais ouais ouais ton cégep le bon sens
aujourd'hui parce que mes ya d'énormes
par exemple d'école mais moi ça
s'applique plus parce que j'ai dit est à
partir des 18 ans je pense que ça pécule
il ya des noms les enfants sur la valeur
et les met sur la volaille délivré
justement moi j'avais j'avais un copain
quatre heure ou deux heures ils
respectaient pas vraiment le même mais
techniquement il yad'énormes d'études
qui profanent moi c'est une passoire sa
fille
les rangs livre
non mais mais j'avais ma mère est
enseignante maintenant si rangers puis
sa job semaine est enseignante de
plateau là et va signer à dix jeunes sur
montréal et que les faits qu'elle
s'adonnait schéma qui est cemac à ma
prof de plateau mais avec des foyers des
tuteurs
ils sont techniquement forcé de faire
faire des devoirs mais en même temps
exactement mais moi de moi même pas que
j'aime l'école mais je voulais finir mon
je veux finir mon sujet puis je fais je
voulais finir mon secondaire fin de mois
même si rousteau que j'avais une pause
de 20 minutes je retournais je faisais
mes devoirs vous ne me forcez pas
vraiment c'était juste s'occuper de
superviser c'était vraiment comme dans
des examens est vraiment le calpi un
mari comme c'est vers là me placer dans
une chambre au dojo aura pas de mouchoir
fêté comme il se définit comme un
changement bon travail sérieux le nom
deux fois leur écoute et on attribue
tout le monde en parle
ouais t'as marc andré turpin à côté qui
dit tabarez très patient mais ça va
vraiment les deux banques comme les gens
d'ici mais c'est vraiment parce que tout
le monde qui rencontrent ma mère et moi
disent qu'on aimerait faire un one man
show qu'on fera jamais le genre musical
t il parce que c'est juste si la
randonnée avec nous tant que c'est pas
tout un drôle parce qu'on s'en va on est
comme tellement proche en même temps on
est toutes ensemble et qu'on se plaigne
vraiment beaucoup mais comme on s'adore
métier en histoire du temps à la maison
mais c'est cool
ouais téléphone hier thomas jack est un
peu
certains des entrevues certains étaient
2 dt roland photographie pitou puis à
chaque fois fallait je retourne sur imdb
pu me dire quel âge à la hausse et
tabarnak 9,9 au jeu le 19 ans si ta
carrière commence à 19 ans tu commences
jeunes ouais c'est ce que je fais me
connais je sais pas si juste qu'il ya
tellement eu six même s'il estime aussi
que des vagues ou qu'on va vraiment se
concentrer sur quelqu'un ça passe d'armé
avec n'importe quel acteur et moi c'est
ce que comme un groupe ipe après la
voleuse élite monde et de fait comme sa
carrière aux états unis est déclenché et
j'obtiens peu fait ça le fait en quelque
sorte dans ce que j'ai extrêmement
choyés puisque lui savent faire un film
américain comme à peu près par année
l'effectif qui n'ont justement pas plein
parce que je sais que des millions
d'acteurs qui s est juste d'avoir filmé
par nikki je tourne n'avait pris un film
par année donc je peux tellement pas me
plaindre mais comme si ça peut fait un
mets ton tu peux te faire peur aux
égoïsmes est ce que tu fais un film avec
steven spielberg puis j'ai entendu comme
des millions de saisies comme ça peu
fait j'aurais kim ascension près
exactement c'est pas comme jour au
lendemain je fais des films année mignon
je tourne avec les predators et aux
unités
ça vaut bien mais je sais pas encore
vraiment je rends vraiment loin net ou
ce que je veux avant tout comme rendu
ses textes et comme difficile parce que
mieux maintenant je suis comme ma jambe
a avancé que je tienne elle soit pour
des rôles ou qu quand pas encore 18 ans
aux etats-unis ils veulent les gens qui
sont bio it in fiction qui ont 18 ans
parce que chez moi pour les normes de
travail de temps allez le voir ne pas
avoir une star ça leur coûte vraiment -
chappuis peut travailler beaucoup plus
d'heures mais pour des ados ils prennent
ça comme tout à fait que j'avais
sympathie rôle là parce que j'avais pas
encore 18 ans puis le maintenant que
j'ai 18 ans je comme dans un créneau
même langue et 19 en fait je connais un
créneau conditionne condor schelin
obligeant qui elle fanning
quand même voter je fais des options
morose et je vois que c'est eux qui ont
eu jusqu'au mais c'est ce genre comme si
comme c'est jusqu'au jeu contre des
filles qui ont d'une façon aux oscars
james a aucun sens que recense le genre
tu veux pas qu'on paie c'est nerveux
excité d'y penser je dis pas que ma
compassion est plus grande au québec
parce que les actrices comme incroyable
ici le mais c'est juste que veut pas
c'est vraiment plus petits au québec t
on à peu près fait une vingtaine de
filles parce qu aux etats unis si on
aime il s'est tu pendant mes marc
fortier dis moi ça va choquer le camp
j'y fais tu t'es andric le l'industrie
au québec on est tout une petite gang
qui vous pondent et tout comme un peu
amis même si on compétitionne linkenholt
bon on se connaît tous on va vraiment
une contente pour les autres
même quand je vais dans une audition je
connais souvent le réalisateur que j'ai
travaillé avec ou type croisé fait que
c'est vraiment comme amical puis comme
calme quand se rendra sans doute si on
ne tue pas c'est un bon bout parce que
moi une fille à voir je me souviens
l'été dernier schaller le singel prend
guppy gaulle et les auditions
non mais ça peut être sans hésiter j'ai
gardé blonde aux yeux bleus est en
attente et à si je m'étais j'avais
capoté parce que jeter comme j'étais
rentrée si nous n'obtenons à montréal
c'est comme on parle plus du personnage
au québec et c'est dit c'est vraiment
chine décline maria puis en fait moi je
lis avril en main ce que j'ai comme
support appris qu'il fallait vraiment
pas que je fasse que c'est vraiment mal
vu que si walter comme québec aux kings
scène michelet imra garde pied comme un
vrai diplôme
why puis comme yvonne est d'alger comme
non je pensais qu'ils allaient jamais
parlé la scène fait qui comme gbagbo au
oui/non ata jourt a besoin d'une chose
c'est que je m'assoie puis le jeu fait
la scène qui me dit aucune rue une
correction qui fait l'arrêt maxime
le gîte est tellement déstabilisé par ce
jeu comme acquis le chevet genre la
deuxième femme je me trompe dans mon
texte parce que je capotais comme à quel
point ce type et 10 ans il est je me
trompe je recommence us des buffets nom
continue jusqu'au maquillage fini la
scène et fait piquer au jeu soja et next
est un autre grand john secondes après
six semaines parce qu'ils n'ont pas le
choix parce qu'ils ont tellement de
filles comptent pas le temps par des
auteurs de 40 minutes et c'est des
options de 5 10 minutes ayant rendu
après ce sucre vraiment réussi à se
démarquer leye rappelle me à thème un
monde s'excite tellement comme moi qui
moi ça m'a vraiment choquée parce que vu
que je fais toutes mes autres sur
montréal je savais pas que c'était comme
ça jusqu'à temps que je rendrais main et
j'imagine aussi que les gens la
compétition est plus féroce pilier
peut-être que la beauce le monde est
plus prêt à tout pour se rendre au top
est ce que tout ça se reconnaissant mais
je connais peu de temps un lit fixons la
pole
assez pour comme sa voile mais c'est sûr
qu'ils étaient la plupart des fils a
beau et ayant comme s'il faut pas kg
ayant pris des cours de chant et ont
pris des cours de diction et ont pris
des cours de danse ils savent tout faire
le trouvant sont préparés à tout pays
c'est comme si selon mme sidibé
notamment ceux qui ont de l'argent mais
celles ci ont besoin de nombreux niveaux
classement l'espagne brune la veille
d'élections ces comices ils s'en foutent
le genre mais qui sait sur qui est ce un
peu mieux préparé que moi des fois qui
comme ses bagages et ouais c'est on
entend on avance souvent que natalie
wood déjà tout le monde travail mettant
dans un café mais qui ont des jobs de
vente commerce et du monde qui ont qui
font des auditions deux semaines pour
tout le web mais peut notamment par tous
mes moyens qu affiche seulement qui
jugent sans qu'un membre du club la base
c'est que ma mare de boue pis ça arrive
souvent que j'avais jordi meeting avec
des real ou des producteurs la bvm6
connu justement l'horaire et si jean
noël wolf sur le chantier s'est tous dit
google travaille le tarif bleu c'était
des espèces de herlies genre on doit et
gps bourgault gens qui sont toutes là en
espérant d'avoir un rôle
quelqu'un un producteur face comment lui
fit il qu'il y aurait des méthodes et
real tu vas y prends un café
cette place est vraiment reconnu pour
avoir des gens qui y est c'est fou
comment chitika maquis en haut du monde
qui veulent le suc sont au top c'est
tellement si le jeu tu as menti mettons
des filles comme aston nous c'est pas la
télé
c'est tellement des surhumains comment
dire c'est son son beau sont bons sont
ils arrivent en entrevue son droid
comment tu fais pour devenir comme ça
c'est vraiment hallucinant mais c'est et
plastiques
c'est aussi des fois c'est que ceux qui
démontent mais c'est pas tout le temps
cela at il sciemment les entretiens du
chemin les entrevues avec un mouton
jimmy fairly nous comme un alien shooter
des millions des questions avant sauf
qu'à répondre c'est ainsi tout un truc
de marketing de publicité les savent
exactement ce qu'ils vont dire d'avant
ce pour que ce soit drôle parfois rire
pour avoir d'avoir une personnalité
comme ceux là profitez croiser en
backstage fait comme ailleurs été
maîtres du genre qu'est ce que ça prend
mettant la combinaison d'événements
slash talence lâche tu pas aux
apparences ou d'éducation pour pour
réussir pour percer ce c'est quoi ces
cas l'addition toutes ces affaires le
soumettons adoptant un ton docte un rôle
mais si je sais ça joue parce que
tellement de facteurs 6 à la phase i
can't you come the beat et si ça prend
un mix de tout événement ne peut pas
être juste au parce que c'était vraiment
c'est un accent beau mais c'est parce
que c'est ça aussi ça dépend chaque côté
tu as fait que jose beau mais autant
qu'il y en a qui sont vraiment justes
bout qui sont mauvais comédiens qui sont
en faisant des films patent bon mais qui
sont quand même des millions mais si
bien et je te manquer son sont bons qui
sont vraiment pas beau mais ti pon
pareil parce qu'ils sont juste voir
vraiment talentueux texto mix de tout
mais c'est vrai que maintenant ça fait
un peu partie l'aiem justement dalle en
entrevue pis je trouve ça plate parce
que dis-je parler soit on aime les au
score me dont six thèmes c'est dommage
parce que c'est tellement plus un truc
de talent il ya toute une campagne
derrière ceux ci payent des publicistes
des et des centaines d'ennemis qui
convient vraiment beaucoup d'argent qui
vous est ce qu'on est comme une campagne
élections très mal la politique c'est de
la politique c'est comme dans quel
magazine type si toi tu pourras dans ce
magazine leur en été c'est toute une
équipe qui travaillèrent se fixe il
passait juste si pas juste du talent
c'est ce que tu montes au public le
public thème du japon ont déjà pris le
dessus parce que et drôle hein mais ça
me pesait
pis je sais c'est déplorable trouvent
les paysages corses soient rendus là
durant la difficulté à
c'est ça reste le plus gros prix qu'il
est plus gros prix qui sont donnés mais
moi j'ai comme de moins en moins
d'intérêt parce qu'à chaque année on
dirait que c'est c'est toujours ses
avances avec le sujet d'un film zac et
les y ont attaqué un sujet qui est
politiquement show fm va avoir beaucoup
de personnes m'en parler le spike lee
valley faire un discours par exemple on
vieillit pas gagnée par exemple juste à
côté c'était pas lui évitait flux basque
et pagani c'est le greenbook qui a
grandi meilleur film jamais testé ou des
façons de secours
le gagnant gagnant quelque chose pensé
monter puis à lui un truc
on s'épaule on veut google et après mais
ouais si c'est ce que tu lises qui comme
tendance puis comme se sont faites a dit
quitter comme pas raciste mais comme il
y avait passé de scène culturelle au
score il y en a comme acheter plein pas
si je serai en même temps mais j'imagine
qu'ils étaient aussi le concept de
l'académie c'est que c'est comme
pleinement de l'industrie qui choque les
films peu chez eux pisser je pense que
c'est su que souvent mettons-les ce qui
va quand même pas vu nécessairement les
dix femmes animations encore de
meilleurs films y ont vu ces puits
tandis qu'il me tendait un festival un
jury demande pertinent laciné mox à son
tour une table qui discutent qui
débattent pour trouver ce que le
meilleur film qu'ils ont trouvé j'ai
l'impression whissell échantillon plus
restreint mais moins la démarche est
plus c'est clair qu'ils ont tous deux vu
les films c'est que quand on discute et
qui ont choisi le meilleur film selon
tout le monde qui est autour de la table
et c'est peut-être mieux comme façon de
faire je sais pas toi de la can oui
c'est une expérience sur elle est un peu
j'ai pas été comme moi j'étais un
canevas pour la grande compétition on
était dans la quinzaine des réalisateurs
mais c'était vraiment c'est ce téléphone
et on est comme une standing-ovation
nous quand on a présenté notre film
piste est comme quoi sert plus débile
mental puis et je suis vraiment amusant
9 à toulouse entrevue sur le bord de la
mer
marcum est cependant une espèce des
pièces de chanter tout liste des
entrevues généralement le fait dans des
pièces de chambres d'hôtel et vas tu
vois le même code il fait chaud parce
qu'elle est il un bac de l'eau ça se
fait comme suit bord de la mer comme
dehors pi2 comme ceux de la rue est
bloquée vêtements de se promène partout
et c'est vraiment le fun mais en même
temps comme moi c'est vraiment raciste
et j'ai fait le les marches ce mardi
je trouve qu'il ya tellement de monde
c'est même plus regardée par un juge
quillethon non par tout et comme 1-1
puis moi je comme tu tellement une
journée fixe plante tout en japonais
mushi wallon le set up à cannes est
juste moche à lille un couple d'années
parce que mon frère il réalisateur
peut-être quelques icônes et s'appelle
pascal plante ce que fait un film
s'appelle les faux tatouages oui c'est
quoi qu'ils en disent beaucoup d'années
luxe en équipe et y aller parce qu'ils
avaient un film qui était dans les
marchés la baule qui est à l'est avec
1,02 ptc
deux jours avant à cannes c'est comme
commence à monter des trucs mais tu te
sens pas trop qui va de quoi le comme sa
porte puis le genre toutes les vedettes
sont le pigeon huge pis ces gros pitié
dans un set up qui était une des plus
belles places au monde le thé le bord de
méditerranée au sud de la france est
comme ça juste pas de bon sens puis
c'est bobby la mer clients et mon temps
c'est incroyable et moi j'avais juste
rue se place que j'avais j'ai pas eu la
chance d'avoir aucun film par exemple
quand tu es là pour ton fema thouars est
tellement chargé avec les entrevues pour
ton film c'est à coacher fête foraine et
seulement respirer pendant une semaine
juste pour le fun c'est costaud que le
fait que tu avais enfin être moins chez
toi que j'ai pas vu aucun film en fait
quand je suis à lille mais c'est
vraiment ce succès de quoi vivre j'ai
géré tomber n'importe quand partout
l'accueil
[Rires]
penses tu que en fait à ce que tu as
déjà
est ce que tu t'es déjà questionné par
rapport au fait s'il fallait que tu tues
des ménages pour continuer à avancer
dans ce milieu là dans ce domaine là
parce que j'imagine que ça doit être un
incitatif à ne pas te prendre pour les
réalisateurs de droit l faut la faire
venir jusqu'ici
ouais ouais c'est sûr que si c'est un
toc que j constamment avec ma famille et
se fait comme trois ans qu'on en parle
du thym et à la base on voulait
déménager mais j'avais pas encore 17
juin pendant 18 ans je découvrais ce à
quoi cette façon je comcast et si ce
cessez-le-feu du togo avec mon cégep que
ma mère aimerait vraiment que je finisse
mon sujet - on dirait que c'est quand
même gros le sait que je veux déménager
mais est-ce que je vais déménager le
tout seul
choqué c'est un peu intense comme même
pas n'a pas seuls en ce moment à
montréal puis comme un gros step 2
échangez pays qui en fait le plus gros
problème j'irai avec ma soeur et ma mère
ma soeur le point qu'on finit sur
secondaire et qu'on sait pas si on veut
la faire bouger puis le plus gros
problème en fait c'est moi si je
déménage faire aimer des gens de mes
avantages canadien dans son j'ai plus
d'assurance à tout en été ça je peux pas
juste y aller si moche pied en ce moment
je sais que je peux pas y aller plus que
six mois par année sans perdre ça fait
qu'il ya des grosses démarche à faire
des démarches de fougères chercher genre
wincor il faut que je cherchais une cape
de travail t&d gros et marc schaefer
fait que c'est ce qu'on regarde en ce
moment parce que moi j'ai un peu dans un
point de vue de lillers cégep
oui c'est important si oui je veux le
faire en même temps que j'explique ce
que je suis en train de faire un des
camps cinéma pour déménager là bas faire
alors que tu as déjà steve d'avant sur
ma demande il s'est fait pourquoi tant
de chercher un deck qui veut peut
maintenant n'est pas parce qu'un usa
tout temps été mon plan après mon dec
d'aller aux états unis avant d'aller à
l'université aix com pourquoi je fais
pas juste y aller le ou est-ce que je
finis mon des cavs a fait que je suis
championne dans le processus en ce
moment d'en parler j'ai cette voie glee
gens j'essaie de voir comment je peux
faire
et pour pas cher et ça me stresse de
bouger le tulle le point instant je
pense que ce que je vais faire je vais
tourner dans deux séries le bientôt je
vais tourner mais je tenais à quelque
chose puis je pense qu'ils font des
mains des hommes et la version anglaise
qu'on devrait comme des buts et j'espère
c'est que je me suis dit je vais faire
ma marque prochaine session je pense que
je vais leur faire vraiment puis il ya
comme le parler de season qu'on appelle
aux etats-unis comme en janvier février
mars qui comme le trois mots qui
casquent pour que le monde tourne pas le
dos de leurs 16 de leurs séries fixé
comme tu as des outils en bac à bac le
temps donne comme 3 4 par semaine fait
qu si comme je me suis dit ce que je
ferai c'est que j'irai peut-être trois
mois parce que pendant ce temps la
piscine book de quoi tant mieux je veux
bout qui je veux tourner resterez lot et
puis sinon mais je reviendrai finir ma
dernière session ou comme les quatre
groupes qui montent manqué puis après ce
devrait stagner avec ma soeur qui fini
on va aller là-bas métissé syndrome
ouvrent leur décision c'est comme si
annalynne miami au complet le cours et
les comptes des caisses qui voit quoi
qu'est ce que ça vient tout seul parce
qu'il est allemand mois le singel
cependant droit qui est m'allume pendant
qu'ils veulent c'est comme la californie
où il passe rousseau paul heckly
colossaux mais comme on dirait que c'est
trop focus et sur l'industrie que j'ai
l'impression que c'est une autre
mentalité vraiment le ch à gauche tourne
avec des filles de le nôtre mindset puis
comme juste la façon dont l'argent qui
est comme leur priorité sont vraiment
pas les mêmes
il fait que j'ai tout a voulu comme
apple d'avoir mettons dans l'idéal
démons l'avoir comme ma maison à
montréal une maison en californie pour
avoir comme la californie parce que s'il
faut ni wable stéphane landry joie mais
on dirait que c'est tellement plus
grande et montréal si c'est la seule
place mkt je pense extrêmement qu'un
ultime m céline dion disait qu'il
pouvait marcher sans et s'amassent faire
courir après si c'est moral je pense
initial passe dans le monde que tout
comme pascal et ça gèle tu viens
tellement rapidement comme un objet puis
comme tout le monde de court après que
j'ai pas envie moins de vivre ces stress
l'aide pour pouvoir sortir de chez nous
qui avons quelqu'un qui tente plantée
devant chez moi c'est ridicule un mec je
pense que c'est cet idéal des demandes
sera moins pire dans les deux se
seraient jamais de comme ce serait
d'aller à l'essentiel pour être capable
de me faire un nom depuis d'être capable
de com a vu ce que je veux être une fois
que je suis le sait jouer un peu avec
les deux j'avais besoin
il suffit d'un gros rôle qu'on sait que
des fois c'est un peu la chance ici qui
est un truc pas inquiète m
il ya tellement de films this fond c'est
ça se pourrait qu'il peut pas savoir
d'avancé j'ai dit on il eu des bons
scénarios puissent embarquer dans le
projet qui finalement s'ajuste à pogny
comme un sérieux pas voir de rien
finalement c'est que parce que tout cas
tu retournes je sais pas dans le fond le
produit fini est ce que c'était arrivé
de sabine non mais tu en prends le film
piège
c'est tout il est fait tant mieux c'est
tellement d'autres étapes de la
réalisation le montage toutes les peaux
post production sans échange de films x
c'est que quand j'étais au touquet comme
j'aimerais vraiment car c'est un flop ce
pas que c'est un flop mais si comme je
parle en mon mari comme la la voleuse
elissa thème intégraux
internationalement ça a été avec fox qui
comme l'un des plus grands studios qui
après ça j'ai tout fait ce genre de
films indépendants qui ont pas tant
politiquement wista la can mines dreams
métiers saas a pas de tampon nyfix pour
ça que j'ai dit que depuis la volaille
zeliv oui je tournais 2 aux états unis
métier je fais pas des films qui ont
aucune domination en import export ce
jeudi par marc est un flop mais c'est
pas ça mais même si ça lui servait
vraiment kg d'héroïne que 1 mettons je
pensais que mon personnage a light
incroyable y avait là une vérité comme
bad ass pic finalement tard et sur le
jour du tournage sont com - mais
finalement le fait pour le public dès 12
ans donc on va enlever toutes les fois
où que tous ceux qui aiment tout ce que
tu va proposer quitte comme un peu trop
méchant on va le coupé effectif c'est
que ça dépend pis si oui ça prend un bon
acteur mais comme c'est pour ce que moi
je pense que tout le monde sur un
plateau tournage est égal parce qu'un
aimant suffit qu'une personne soit pas
bonne dans ce cas fait que ça impacte le
film au complet que ce soit en éclairage
en montage en sont tout un pack le film
donc personne qui meilleur qu'un autre
sur un plateau de tournage puis ça
arrive que tu tournes avec un real
battant mont pics à scrap infime de même
demain beau et de bon il faut comme en
montage
même si c'est incroyable comme acteur la
façon dont ils veulent monde était comme
un attentat prix ne réplique de comme la
troisième tekki pop pareil a cité dans
la première avec le gie la de mal jouer
parce qu'ils me les répliques sont pas
pareils d'enlever toutes des silences
que je donnais ce qui fait que l'on
dirait que jan chan milling comme un
blog web qu'effectue ça ça arrive c'est
la majorité est un peu pour pas mal tout
le monde personne qui fait que chacun
ses rôles
c est le genre tu regardes les meilleurs
acteurs sont gardés de johnny depp y en
ait fait des films qui étaient commis et
qu'il a fallu noble mais sans encombre
que le fait qu'ils sont manquants il est
regardé il ya peu fait comment ils
soient film ne marche jamais marqué de
danser ya sûrement pas essentielle pi ca
de [ __ ] ça peut fonctionner mais qui
s'est même dégradée octobre a vraiment
quelqu'un qui écoute les femmes qui ont
fait même si le mettons nous au ton
écoute on trouve ça bon je te vois plein
afin que nous autres on voit pas moi pis
si damon a aussi de quoi tu le tour
n'est effectué perçoit police à naître
de la même façon petit comme moi je me
chargerai adeline says je me suis et je
me suis né comme tout ce qui était
derrière ce but je me sais que sur telle
réplique je pensais à telle affaire
c'est dans le monde pour qu'on peut pas
le voir d'une façon et subjective
objectif le dernier qui sortent si le
film d'action ouais avec la fille qui
joue dans un millenium - nomique encore
non plus et oui ces cas maintenant la
différence entre jouer un film d'action
puisse jouer un film plus plus près des
sentiments pour toi comment tu l'as
proches différemment mais je dirais que
comme un film mais en fait ce film est
quand même près de mes sentiments parce
que justement il y avait beaucoup de
scènes que que je suis paniqué beaucoup
mais ce que j'ai trouvé drôle ont simulé
ce qui est souvent drôle mais c'est que
je me trouve je me retrouvais souvent
comme paniqué un peu pour vrai parce
qu'il est gay et zellik omni qui n'a
peur je les connaissais
tant pis on au maroc piste est décédé
marocain que je connaissais vaguement
peu pour mon film est comme un homme
avait-il dit non mais il fait un peu
peur pour vrai il parlait pas anglais
mais qui commence à me peser vraiment
forte savaient leur réalisme et moi
j'étais comme avant de faire des docks
avec comme pagis est on n'a pas au moins
c'est qu'il y en a qui étaient vraiment
faim qui lui jamais il venait de londres
may en ayant une coupe que je te manges
je te connaissais pas tant que çà mau
comme fischer
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait ouvrez parce
que moi c'était pas tant les scènes
répétitives comme nous mit et le chemin
avait plus des scènes de faillite parce
que moi c'est surtout de l'autodéfense
vraiment n'est pas vraiment pratique
pour ça et c'était vraiment juste défend
toi j'essaie de me débattre
j'avais dit vraiment note j'avais mal au
poignet puis elle a elle-même à la vie
comme assez punchy pia derniers mois
j'avais aujourd'hui blue autour des
poignets mai mais n'ont fait que ça
faisait comme du foie savait pas ouvrir
justement pitt et il y en a qui sont
vraiment comme dans leur personnage je
suis vraiment pas quelqu'un
merci de mai à nexon personnage auteuil
qui viendra pas
j'étais un peu cuit bien
à l'aise mais ça fait quand même j'ai
vraiment aimé ce et je leur ferai 100%
mais si c'est moins sage et comme proche
de mes sentiments quand même vu que
c'était une autodéfense
je me sentais comme pas tant mais
j'étais pas dans mon pays je t'ai pas
dans des termes plus sûr en l'équipe
poussine est du maroc s'est retourné
dans dix ans dans des endroits vraiment
trash le ti expression souvent quand les
gens me demandaient ce que j'ai mis ma
rocks ma réponse est non parce que j'ai
juste vu ni endroit super trash du maroc
qui ont tourné dans les espèces de sucre
salloukh moi j'avais pas j'avais peu de
sandales je courais dans la piscine
terral mange en juillet comme dit des
trucs de pièces y avait aujourd'hui les
gens il ya des scolioses à côté j'en
avais dijon qui avait comme une jambe
partout piché comme rojas et je voyais
ça tous les jours pour cellectis mais
l'équipe complet de tournage ici c'est
plutôt mal parce que tout si nous ne la
bouffe et en europe tout comme pour les
acteurs
je me sentais tellement mal si comme
support mais si bon parce que ça ça te
met en place un terme à sa place mais
comme je me suis approchée comme à qui
je suis vraiment vraiment choyé d'avoir
agi j'ai même temps quand ça fait trois
semaines que tu vois ce c'est comme j'ai
compris ça dit juste vraiment lourd et
que moi si je suppose et puis le
il ya le film d'eric woerth y en a un
autre qui s'appelle de rêve mais c'est
quoi ce film c'est un film que j'ai
tourné et indemnités comme va à peu près
un an puis ces histoires des quatre
filles et quatre femmes dans le fond y
mêmes moyens que moi ma mère kim mon
père divorcé ma mère et à l'histoire
comme une nouvelle famille avec 7 puis
il ya une crise cardiaque je pense mais
c'est une fois correctement je pense
qu'ils ont changé de monsieur pense qu'à
l'image des débits moyens
puis cette deuxième femme il se rend
compte que dans le fond le parent était
cité bloc puis se retrouve en dette qui
seront comme saisir la maison avec moi
ma mère est comme se sent mal qu'ils
invitent à venir rester chez nous
mexique comme capcom deux familles qui
se détestent impie quatre femmes qui
s'aiment peines en mangeant comme des
relations familiales en même temps donc
sommes tous liés par le deuil de cet
homme le fait que c'est comment y vivent
séparément mais ensemble avec sa sexy
comme si vraiment il dit le sait peu
mais c'est vraiment ici langue ne payez
pas vraiment beaucoup d'action il se
passe pas grand chose c'est vraiment
juste la réalité de comme des quatre
femmes font face à haas et de l'appui
comment ils réagissent ensemble rapport
à ceux de tournai où a été tourné au
canada y ait beaucoup de choses qui sont
faites au canada
ouais j'ai trouvé un truck and bus
j'avais une mine gym chemin qui est à
cannes s'est détournée à sousse
anne-marie dans les fins fonds
[Musique]
j'ai fait pareil je me tiens il y avait
tellement pi2g comme il y avait
tellement personnes à chaque fois je me
suis mis fin de semaine je recroise est
le mélange à la libye ce report croisé
genre quatre personnes le bateau
tournage en tout temps si c'est
tellement petit un aimant je pense que
je pouvais marcher la tête et l'autre en
complétant une journée d'oublier
population de la ville a vraiment
vraiment je m'essayais que je connais à
montréal je prenais le métro était comme
richard songbook sortie hiver mais je
regardais tout le monde jusqu'à 50
autres épaules dans ma vie de tous les
jours prendre le métro brecht ainsi mais
même à greek et comme il ya des paysages
vraiment extra et coutumes en cage et on
a notre vie mais comme je pense que
c'était un des tournages du plus facile
en jeu le tournage est facile à vie
parce que l'enfant mon personnage c'est
une fille qui s'entend comme poste par
bien que sa mère
beck vraiment résister comme un peu la
relation que j'ai avec mamadou avait su
xianze puis il faisait tellement beau
puis comme les gens étaient justes c'est
fou comment l'équipe de tournage c'est
vraiment vraiment un impact sur comme le
déroulement et du film c'est déjà
démasqué comme j'avais l'impression
qu'on t il gagne dans un chalet gens
maintenant un mois considéré on va
tourner les trucs en deux styles tels
qu'on tournait pas on était tout seul
est bord d'une piscine à comme ça à
bronzer sur l'heure du lunch piste est
vraiment et c'est vraiment le fun que
les tarifs ajustements bgi pas encore vu
mais chérif a dû idiote parce qu'après
vous comprends pas ce genre des voiles
qui est salle r effectivement ce plateau
était le genre et dans mes méthodes
actives au québec avec ma fille n'est
que ça marche comme nom pour les
personnes j'ai une question pour toi
mais attend que je regarde toutes les
rôles et les rôles en général les
personnages au fil stack
quelles sont mes tantes en top 3 des
requêtes auraient voulu faire
je suis mis c'est pas un personnage de
gore en fait mais celle qui avait joué
baissé en fait c'est quand il y en a
d'autres caprio qui avait joué je me
suis dit c'est bon
happy animals je comprends même pas
pourquoi y'a rien gagné pour seul
viatique en hausse car je pense mais
pourquoi il peut gagner les îles en
langue est trop bon pêcheur et sean eux
mêmes
bref on dirait que ça me fait vraiment
remettre en question pourquoi je suis
dans le cinéma quand je vois une
performance aussi bonne assange le jeu
comme ça pas sans sexe et c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui m'avait marketing
urbain savaient marcher qu'à moi
j'aurais aimé avoir un truc de même je
pense que ce ou cognac sommes trop truc
soit un iphone 3g comme pas deux lignes
spécifiques mais soit ça justement un
truc d'un handicapé soit un espèce de
film d'action gens vraiment action
commet avengers ou alors vraiment que
comme fou que je me prépare physiquement
pour le training d'un an
huawei ses yeux je reste ça me tenterait
quand même maintenant c'est de mettre en
fond d'avoir un entraîneur comme je veux
juste par un rôle qui me force à me
[Musique]
nourrit c'est moi ou ce nom m
une comédie parce que j'ai jamais fait
des comédies hamelin plupart parce que
tourner comme un ca dre genre tellement
et le fun dit drôle mais est quand même
c'est difficile à dire c'est tellement
difficile parce que j'ai l'impression
que comme jouer des rôles dramatiques
pour moi c'est plus facile mais pas son
geste et où puisez je sais qu est-ce qui
va me faire pleurer puis je sais comment
le faire mais faire une comédie audrey
que je sais pas si je serai drôle
londres est que ça me sortir de ma zone
de confort parce que j'ai un peu
quelqu'un que pas du ridicule puisque
peur de me faire juger que j'ai
l'impression que essayer de faire rire
les gens ça me serait à faire des
enfants qui je fais pas nécessairement
pee wee curieuse de voir est une comédie
jeudi j'ai fait des parents le
est une comédie comme j'aimerais ça va
être difficile
c'est comme vraiment une question de
timing comment se place des blagues des
réactions faciale du coup je n'ai jamais
fait quelque chose quel genre
complètement faux ouais ouais des quads
drôle faut vraiment soit drôle pour que
ce soit drôle ou ferro apparemment sur
un plateau de tournage son objectif à
chaque thé lui c'est de l'impro qui fait
pratiquement le trio son scénario mais
lui sait s'ils viennent dit viens
domaine le profit son but à chaque take
c'est de faire rire l'appliquant
novateur paquet car c'est son autre
acteur c'est le show de l'épreuve que
j'ai eu à faire parce que c'est le gars
le plus drôle que j'ai rencontré ce
genre fait capoter moins d'un quart de
rester sérieux et moi j'essaie juste des
façons les parents comme une fact un
four est d'être capable de me calmer
fait que m saint paul
au début c'est drôle moi ça marche mais
là les gardiens way avec les jardins
deux camps dans la ligne juste et que
sarah vit mal à rire avant qu'il aille
mais parce que c'est comme une seconde
tient et ça ça se déclenche tout seul
way back c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui m'intéresserait je pense que je
trouve ça extrêmement celle de pourrir
avoir quelqu'un qui me fait des phases
devrait stipuler puis c'est quand il y
en a une qui est drôle claude déjean
franchi gonflé qu'à le regarder car on
vraiment sérieux vraiment chose qui me
fait plus rire que je les bloopers
tellement drôle quand il rajoute en
ligne après justement si c'est quelque
chose qui on remet ainsi de tout temps
forts pics justement comme j'ai peur du
ridicule
jose jamais acheté des lignes après ou
d'imiter tout temps vraiment hot
extension ce que je m'approprie le texte
à ma façon mais je vais jamais comme
acheter des lignes à la fin
parce que je comme j'avais tellement
peur de dire quelque chose qui se sont
quand même me gamal eid passe comme je
suis comme toi qui offre cette
proposition l'appui des lycéens migrants
sub à tout petit quand moi je n'ai pas
qu'il est en liberté afin dé sainte pour
dire essayer de quoi ou des soins et
laisse comme un 3 4 secondes de plus
pour comme le garder l'attend dans
l'émotion or en pivot qui en un chamakh
décidé comme rajouter des lignes aimé ça
mais ça l'est pas ni real aussi en
action extrêmement comme ce truc
ouais moi j'agis travailler avec un
réalisateur qui est tellement pas le fun
parce qu'il dit et quelles mains des lui
qui avait écrit ce scénario fait qd il y
tenait
mais c'est maintenant aux émeutes ont
jamais dit que j'avais des gros
paragraphe kim dont je faisais une
énumération de comme des fruits et je
pense que j'y faisais ça me fait une
énumération permettons vous êtes des
bananes avant pomme dont le texte est
comme avant dans une plaine de jeux
comme monsieur jean comprenez-vous que
comme gigean des mots et des mois après
que péter des fois ci c'est too much pc
plate un peu quand je te demande pas sa
liberté le petit fort ça comme rentrer
dans une version des choses que tu veux
pas faire un cas précis les gens
justement c'est pas même si rémy jouer
même si ce succès pas avant de commencer
le tournage si si avec le titre fait
comme un peu bachir après d'image mais
je m'étais fait bâcher pour des affaires
sur mon jubilé comme tu le sais j'en
suis pas bon c'est pour moi qui voulais
c'est que j'avais pas le choix de le
part demain il a même envoyé chis non
vie comme un gosse qui allumèrent les
fruits la nema ça va tellement bien sûr
décidément pas fonctionné
imagine t callaway cadres et à l'écrit
c'est encore plus people
waouh ça dépasse juste sur un ça va mais
j'ai sonné mais je suis quand même des
bonnes la plupart des tournées sont
vraiment fun et j il y en a vraiment dit
foule dans ce monde puis j'ai je pense
que organisateurs puissamment - moi y
avait pas été comme ça que moi et je
tourne avec un enfant d comme je pense
qu'il y avait 8 ans les petits gars qui
était pas capable de pleurer puis le
réal pour qu'ils se mettent à pleurer
commencé à se mettre derrière la caméra
mouassa l'envoyer chier jean paquin bas
la cupidité comment ma gueule et qui dit
[ __ ] de l'équipe c'est juste mis à
pleurer puis comme je regardais le
monsieur à l'ippj t comme mène jamais
vraiment mis mal à l'aise comme il y en
a vraiment pour tous peut pas faire ce
même si pour l'heure le psy pour y
arriver quelque chose peut pas traiter
des dot.com semaine on sait cette
cigogne est brisé j'espère pour lui
qu'il veut qu'il va se reconstruire mais
sa confiance et ses cantines même de
paul et moi ce jour moi j'ai vraiment ne
me dira autant que comme je quelqu'un
bon caractère autant que j'ai un peu la
misère à stand up pour comme moi même
by je me suis justement j'avais fait un
un tournage comme le real avait commencé
à cribler que soit plus fort chez
monsieur justin va voir faire comme elle
dit plusieurs fois plus franchi ont
commencé à crier jambes j'étais comme
système j'ai crié par le demi mêlée
comme la lâcheté comme un job chez moi
ça m'aide pas du tout laissait vraiment
pas une façon parce que moi ça fait
juste commencé à me stresser pis c'est
pas moi qui va arrêter le tournage va
faire comme est vraiment pas la faire à
me parler comme ce qui changeait pas
encore la force de faire ce pixel qui
tournait avec moi justement elle l'avait
fait parce qu'il y avait commencé à
envoyer chier un pied a fait à les
arrêter en plein milieu qu'elle a
regardé ça fait plus jamais tu me parles
même piège quitter les gens pendant une
demi-heure le plateau l'apprécier y
arrêter de crier métiers y en ait qui
admire et haletant ne sont pas à
remettre à sa place ils vont loin puis
moi je veux juste me laisser prendre
tout puissant mind pas parce que ça me
fait juste comme ça moi ça me rend
vraiment anxieuses à allied aucune
c'est tellement pas nécessaire parce que
comme le meilleur exemple sont les
derniers faits mais que les requins on a
tourné dans des affaires qui sont
incroyablement difficile à faire y'a pas
je pense que c'est une première à tout
cas pas une fois que personne cyrielle
étudier toute l'année 12h10 chicane n'a
causé ni dans le rush peu importe si on
le fait on ne rentrait dans toutes nos
journées on a fait ce qu'on avait à
faire pire ça fait juste mettre une
meilleure ambiance
si je te prouve qu'on peut arriver à la
même affaire sans avoir cette attitude
bleus ça me giffard ça va être une plus
belle expérience c'est tellement pas
nécessaire d'avoir une attitude même
s'il veut la direction d'acteur c'est
tellement de psychologie l'impression au
pit il faut que la nati d'acteurs
appétit
peut-être que pour certaines personnes
c'est des approches qui vont aller mieux
métier si vraiment mal connaître bram et
ont mal connaître j'imagine de penser qu
en criant abrite vous fermez a pas
vraiment s'y rendent pour être un bon
psychologue
non m
je pense que c'est ce une ou deux fois
le ca mais ça m'est souvent arrivé lui
justement qui comme me coachait fâché
parce que j'étais pas capable de faire
ce qui me demandait de faire métier
justement un coach qui connaît vraiment
bien son athlète le voit quand tu
quittes épuisé qui veut juste faire
comme kiczek fait comme elle une fois de
moins une gamme des défauts justement
ils voient le côté pas capable tu
essayes le disais je pense qu'il se
passe souvent quand ils voient que c'est
peu puis comme que tu abandonné quand il
voit que tu essayes mais juste brûler et
souvent ils vont se calmer puis
justement moi je me suis quand je me
fais engueuler par me coacher
achetez j'étais vraiment volume satis à
sa tête pas performé aucunement le moins
6 mai faisant envoyer par mon coach
était pas comme un hacker ouais c'est
vrai je veux le faire si je me force
brutale si je peux également cette
journée est ce parce que je suis pas
capable le fait que je me dis ça mais je
me rende plus stressé que le jeu
devenait plus anxieuse puis je tombais
juste plus comme ton des trucs à la
poutre n'est juste plus tomber parce que
j'ai des goûts notamment ses nerfs que
je tremblais
ouais mais ça m'est arrivé ça m'arrivait
aussi beaucoup parce que non mais
maintenant je l'aï me suivre il ya une
voix du medef m à la cheville puis il ya
beaucoup de filles justement que cai ont
mal vont être comme vont endurer pivot
rien dire ps je me réveille fille qui
s'en prennent à moi j'avais un sentiment
mitigé mais d'un centimètre et continuer
genre à s'entraîner puis comme méjean
foot arrête moi vu que je suis môme ou
depuis supporte mal les mâles usto que
j'avais mal si je le disais mais qu'est
me coachait mais pas trop sûr parce que
ça faisait qu après ça j'étais forcé à
les voir ray safetic et j'ai arrêté de
m'entraîner mais kamoni justement
j'avais commis mame n'diaye t'entraînes
pas aujourd'hui et qui croupissent une
[ __ ] et comme j'étais tellement à
maubeuge et va comme parfait matures
il est comme you come back youpi charge
d'un virus continue marché deuxième et
pognon est remplie clavé piège étrangers
d'échanger club longtemps
by step à jiminix avait changé longtemps
appris l'histoire comme ça c'est un
choix éclairé tous les jours le drame
serait même si c'est un espèce des
rapports de pouvoir vraiment bizarre les
entraîneurs me tarde que ça peut aller
pire que seules étaient dernièrement
avec je te main toute l'histoire des
entraîneurs de l'équipe nationale de ski
alpin et les agressions
ah oui mais j'aime aussi abusif en 250
et fine c'est vraiment un espèce de
le rapport de pouvoir qui juste
dégueulasse qui devient malsain à plein
au niveau pee il ya vraiment un travail
de à faire au niveau des parents juste
pour juste pour que les gens juste pour
ce phare encore nos parents que le coach
pas raison tout le temps pour certains
c'est d'utiliser ton sens critique pour
eux
pour j chuck est ce que tes enfants font
dans le fond était pourtant d'en face en
pour ça une personne que tu connais pas
tant pis si ça réussit aussi dans les
parents qui comme vivre leurs rêves à
366 monomère autant dans la ja style osé
mais c'était quand j ai dit d'arrêter
même si elle fait tellement de
sacrifices pour moi pour me faire
réussir dans ce sport là parce que j'ai
dit que je suive lépine enfer l'accepté
bien être qui pillent même c'est dans le
cinéma
la seconde j'ai dit que je vais arrêter
au contraire même si elle voit jamais je
te vois que tu deviens un peu dans la
tête enflée ou qui comme sylvain plus
respectueuse envers les autres tout
commença comme une plaque roy a dit mme
wadimoff houleux à 10h10 le contrôle sur
mon travail mais comme c est l 100 foule
c'est son but c'est pas que je gagne en
hausse qu'artistique choix comme un bon
humain avant tout ici ça paraît parce
qu'après c'est justement il veut pas me
pousser ne veut pas être sur les
plateaux en train de comme aline gossip
tout le monde puis deux puis justement
ça fait que comme elle une distanciation
dans ce sens qu'il veut pas prendre à la
lettre tous que les real tout ce que
mikko mais c'était un métier tout
tendues à faire là dedans de l'autre
côté ne veut pas non plus jeter ma
taille et des histoires de d'enseignants
mettons que c'est qui qui font juste
mettons intervenir une situation plus
les parents sont jamais content de
commencer ta manif aussi
kim entend des choses enfin la part des
choses aussi doté d avoir confiance en
partie des banques au sud d'hébron
enseignants ou des bons realia la
première majorité dans le fond c'est il
y en a aussi qui sont actives ont avisé
leurs pouvoirs qui vont d'affaires
devrait pas été saisie ces fous vrai
qu'il faut vraiment que parent continue
de décrire des enfants à l'école c'est
un des agresseurs non mais pareil ça
peut être une réflexion qui voit dans la
nouvelle sis à mêler sport cet état
prend tellement de leçon de vie
totalement que toi ce que tu aimes ton
expérience à la jim satisfaire à tous
les moments énormément et c'est une
question qu'on me pose ces chiens et
juste pour mon commun et faisait sens
aérospatiale c'est de faire une routine
à la poutre et d'être concentré sur
comme un 10 cm de matériel pendant que
comme une fille qui court dans le gym
pendant qu'une musique super fort parce
qu'une fille fait une routine au sol
parce que des ballons qui selon ses
proches des toiles de fonction a
concentré agents retourner dans les airs
pire atterrir sur une poutre mots
tellement qu'ils soient cadre de focus
et sur une enfant malgré tout ce qui se
passe alentour de toi ces mêmes enfants
chantent à tour un patou le tournage
c'est fou tu sois concentré sur une
scène pendant que comme 47 ans la claque
à marquer le rythme commence à bouger et
il ya tellement de choses qui se passent
à un club de foot serait ce focus et ou
juste leur méthode sur le fait de
répéter des singles beaucoup de foi
tient le nombre de fois que j'ai répété
les mêmes routines de jim de
persévérance le puy de dôme organisation
aussi de mon oral témoin depuis que jean
troisième année comme j'ai dit je
transporte études donc jeté habitude
jumeler les corps à ce puits de savoir
qu'il faut jamais fini yal'affaire
d'être vraiment réalisées c'est un même
enfant dans le cinéma quand un orage par
chargé après les scènes in-game y songe
écoutant prévenir
ce que je mange à midi ou à une autre il
ya vraiment beaucoup de débats tendus
par les deux séries télé puis ça nous
amène à une question on a des questions
de nos autres histoires du conteur savez
on est on a demandé s'ils avaient
question puis c'est thierry hesse boeing
qui ne manque qu'une parlait que tout
allait tourner dans les séries télé et
prochainement
ouais crois tu qu'il est plus facile de
rendre un hommage de rendre le
personnage de film mémorable compagnon
un personnage de série télé est en est
le format général d'un film fait qd et
en histoire complète pour segmenter puis
l'asu question c'est lequel les deux
références jouer et je pense je pense
pas que s'il y en a un qui mieux qu
l'autre je pense que ça n'est pas
vraiment du personnage que tu peux jouer
dans les deux et si ce qu'est ce qu'ils
font dans les séries tcd fois de plus de
temps pour élaborer le personnage
dépendamment encore de site une série à
long terme
m - le programme en thon rouge ouais des
ventes amendé pendant ton rôle mais
c'est sûr qu'en même temps on dirait que
quand tu écoutes un film ça tu arrives
to one shot puis c'est comme à la fin
c'est un peu plus 7,5 sade mais plus j'y
passe atteint 4,1 meur
et comme impies c'est beaucoup
d'informations en même temps toute la
preuve j'ai même raison que c'est plus
facile d'être comme ébloui par ce parce
qu'une si vite et si bon vite été comme
high tech super bon mais sa coupe de
servian semaine prochaine et qu'on
dirait que comme par segment schultz un
peu plus c'est difficile peut-être des
comme voir l'ensemble des examens puis
moi et générant je pense que j'aime
mieux j'ai mieux joué dans les films
parce que 2 1 je trouve que ça et
skating à sens que moi pourquoi là bas j
j quand j'étais plus jeune je faisais
jamais series parce que j'avais pas
envie d'être étiqueté âme et oracle sont
un terreau proposé plusieurs fois m
il ya une couple de fois puis c'est
aussi à cause que c'est un jeu n'est pas
vraiment être étiqueté c'est hyper comme
un as et elle qui joue dans ce puits on
la connaît pour ses personnages mais
après c'est sûr c'est dur de sortir de
ce m
mais maintenant ce qu'il fait du chemin
c'est qu'il faut beaucoup de trucs de
moutons une saison je sais c'est le fun
c'est ce que moi je préfère faire je
m'ennuie insee
donc quand même temps le monstre ou mais
franchement qu'est est à peu près là le
regard de khimki après s'était pas
attaché à ce titre vient pote pas de ce
que des services fait bloc pour un bon
mutante et des fois ci comme les uns
pendant un an
ça va prendre rien de ça est fixé ce que
moi je trouve généralement difficiles
avec des services qui peut pas prendre
autre chose c'est que j'ai montré que je
peux gmt mars à avoir de quoi de nouveau
dans ma vie tout le temps j'aime pas
trop ce qui est routinier j'ai
l'impression que je suis un film je les
fais c'est fini je pense à autre chose
je pense même que c'est quand jean
ferrat brel au tpi
celui que j'ai fait c'est derrière moi
pensent qu'une série qui dure cinq ans
ouais c'est peut-être juste parce que
j'en ai pas fait aussi que je sais pas
c'est quoi avancer comme ce lien
d'appartenance le mais on dirait que je
sais pas j'aime savoir une nouvelle
équipe james a formé un nouveau lien
piemme ce que megadeth j'ai plus fait je
fais beaucoup plus de films que j moi
j'ai juste fait une mais deux sévi la
formule mini serre il exactement ce que
j'allais chez l'impression que ce
nouveau format de course thierry mathon
de 8 10 épisodes de 40 minutes ou à une
homme qui comme un long film de genre
5,6 a piqué c'est une saison plus que
j'ai l'impression ça va être tourné
aussi en un bloc comme un film plutôt
que mettant à chaque semaine ce 30
points suivants tu peux jouer aussi avec
la avec
la temporalité c'est maintenant les
flashbacks qui que tu peux tout retourné
dans un blog avec les flashback sont
super c'est là qu'ils drop ou 6 à 1 sur
mettant son affliction ce jeu là
vraiment l'impression que c'est comme le
nouveau format nouveau médium qui
devient vraiment au tpiy pete est
peut-être aussi je suis pas aussi tout
récemment il était jadis mettons
peut-être une hiérarchie des d'acteur de
cinéma plus d'acteurs de terrain mais
c'est plutôt des séries comme toutes les
plus grandes actrices et dans ma série
cliquer pili pili mettons les gens
consomment plus ce thème est donc comme
une fois sur netflix sur facebook je
vous demande mes amis écrire quelle
série flics les gens écrivent plus quel
film qui va chez netflix s'est vraiment
rendu là c'est vrai que ça n'a vraiment
changé je pense que c'est justement à
cause du genre de mini série vu que
c'était pas des quotidiennes qui tourne
vite
c'est ainsi que c'est vraiment qualité
film suivi c'est jean marc vallée puis
justement tu sais que c'est pas ça pas
été une quotidienne qui était rentré que
tu avais de fait une fois comme dans 30
vies de droit détectée par le prix
beaucoup d'hommes ça le prix le temps
que ça prend de tourner un film c'est
pour ce que c'est bon pied avant c'est
vrai que ses seuls succès faisaient les
films faisait les films puissent essayer
mais maintenant ça me donne jamais la
leçon les deux ou si c'est pour ça que
je pense que c'est le fun parce que moi
je me suis mais je me suis justement se
forme au lot de communes épisode je
trouve que c'est c'est parfait
puisqu'elle chemin ya bien eu beaucoup
de séries aussi qui en font pas une
deuxième saison parce qu'il ya en son
genre le besoin juste pour plaire aux
deux stars sont comme moi c'est ce que
j'avais appris récemment rester à ce
point porte que des gens veulent à la
suite il est à l'aise
est-ce que j'ai rêvé qu'il faisait une
deuxième saison
nouaille enfin une deuxième
mais je pense qu'il y participe quand
même d'une certaine façon c'est une
réalisatrice c'est qu'ils font qu'elle a
fait monsieur eu et c'est une bonne
réalisatrice
est-ce que ça c'était de la bombe je
l'avais écouté one shot dans l'avion qui
se rendait jusqu'à ben ali oui il avait
faire tout à fait mon vol montréal doit
combler écoutez si j'avais écouté
patiemment c'était celle qui fait le
reste revenant voici sa blonde est qui
et qui
ce que j'ai vraiment de voir mon film
basque et y sont projetés elle apprend
évidemment je pense que c'est comme son
premier film qu'elle fait là des masters
j'ai trouvé qu'il l'aï regardé avant que
ce soit finale b je pense que je pense
et j'ai toujours je dois je pense qui
comme il participe un peu et je pense qu
il n est dit et puis il a aidé un peu
dans le montage le tiche proxy qui
montre le film était elle s inspire de
lui je sais notamment dans la façon
qu'on a tourné
bing de volaille s'était tourné sans
aucune lumière artificielle et c'est
tout et lumière du jour
ça fais en sorte que il comme un concept
que tu peux tourner la caméra genre 180
degrijse comme une règle un peu non
écrit que peu de temps parce le sycot
mais c'est comme tout parce qu'elle et
lui fait vraiment la liberté je pense
que c'est surtout tenez à l'épaule puis
vu que personne auto et comme il peut se
déplacer qu'en qu'il veut fait que comme
plus de règne et que c'est vraiment
comme ça aussi que nous on a tourné deux
restent vost qui avait aucune lumière
même la nuit le même site un tournage de
nuit d'habitude on est énorme lumière
qui éclaire et non nous c'était comme la
lumière de nos téléphones tous des
universités des lumières émeutes ont une
lumière de lampes de chevet ça faisait
justement sorte qu'elle explique
maintenant dans big love
la scène finale où est-ce qu'ils sont
comme un dans un parti le soir qui a
plein de lumière chinoise partout ouais
pic l'éclairage est vraiment c'est
vraiment esthétique c'est ça s'ils font
que masquer pour nous sinon ce qu'on
aime en tant qu'acteur s'il joue il sait
pas la tente
cette attaque qui manque d'éclairage et
que ce que j'ai mais non jamais c'est le
fun parce que on pouvait tourner autour
beaucoup plus rapidement parce que l'eau
stockée comme tune in fine on fait juste
changé il n'y a pas d'autres s'étaient
un peu des fois pour monter la caméra
mais il ya pas de ses tableaux comme un
communiqué rage pillet qu'on a tourné
c'est la moyenne je dirais pour un film
la ccc semaine après le tournage qui
nous on le fait en quatre pour la même
[Musique]
carrosserie est on a rentré en toutes
nos journées c'est comme rouler
constamment avec apple tente emmerder
comme tout le temps dans l'action fait
qu'ils essaient vraiment le fun que j'ai
vraiment de quoi voir de quoi ça mais ça
m'a bien des fois l'éclairage ça peut te
rendre vraiment belle fixe à ce petit
jeu là la maladresse et ça je pense pas
que ça va être
estelle et coulis et moi le film avec le
puits qt m'attend mais ça va être le
film le plus réaliste est cool c'est que
cette année kubrick pour le film barry
lyndon n'y avait aucun éclairage comme
ceux qui s'étaient des scènes
d'intérieur éclairé à la chandelle
oui je les vis en qui il ait fallu
qu'ils prennent voir des objectifs de
fait la nasa n'est fait à part d'avoir
assez de lumière salle et construit ses
propres ailes en six mois c'est ça
aucun sens quel point était plus tôt
dispendieux tous les tournages 120 m et
les gels et du cgri demain des hommes
c'est la série d'accidents qui ont
appelé leur fronde engagée s'est passé
tout le même casque moi j'ai trouvé ça
drôle m'ont fait venir au sionisme comme
on veut vraiment tester ton anglais la
télévision vous appelle moi j'en
rajoutais du ndc rama comme l'audience a
plus qu ils m'ont posé des questions en
anglais comme le real quand je suis
désolé mais je ne sais pas si c'est
qu'ils du cast original dans la version
anglaise comme je parle de ces
augmentations contourner le mois six
comme j com mais je me suis dit qu'il y
avait probablement des choses qu'on le
fasse à ce que les postures à 100% mais
fecteau a pu noter je vais faire une
autre messe affectionnant est
socialement et si je sais pas des fois
ça je me fais dire
lundi j'ai aussi ma blonde
en fait ce n'est pas fort pour une pièce
de théâtre et on le fait on était en
conférence à chicoutimi dans la vie
jarne chambre d'hôtel pour la conférence
de talent et que moi je donne la
réplique
je suis passé à 6 80 on en parle avec
moi je donne la réplique pis
je ne savais vraiment pas comment me
positionner les fallait comme casse
poche après mon personnage que c'était
la pire situation parce que j'aurais
écrit a pris plus jeter en chambre
d'hôtel chacun là j'ai pas envie de
lever le ton ici les liban vis de lire
ce qui marque et leur a en même temps on
faisait de moi un peu quelque chose le
fait que jack tu sais quoi d'ailleurs
mais c est ce qui donne la réplique à
jude et sud où elle fait l'italienne
qu'on a comme ce coin mais d'habitude et
y joue le web mais d'habitude cm temps à
montréal
et ouais mais je suis descendu manger
oms ça n'est pas lyonnais qui justement
engage
je pense que le meilleur c'est de jouer
mais c'est sûr que le meilleur cesserai
de le faire avec quelqu'un il capable de
mes capacités je fais moi c'est jusqu'à
1 marque un essai jouissent ne joue pas
mais je pense que le mieux c'est de
jouer quand la lépi souvent moi j'avais
fait j'étais allée actif et qu'il a fait
sur le tronçon est vrai une couple
d'années puis j'étais comme eux le tiff
rising pour ce j'étais obligé de suivre
des cours déjà de cours dont mike
phillips
tiens quel point c'est rendu plate et
j'en avais un cours sur les réseaux
sociaux
en quoi que les réseaux sociaux
maintenant ça aide à qom puis c'est vrai
on passait dix fois les pistes
j'approuverai qu'on ne reçoit acteurs
concernés des cours sur comment
augmenter nos réseaux sociaux pour
comment avoir plus de rôles parce que
maintenant le film si des fois vaut
castet des gens qui ont beaucoup
d'abonnés parce qu'ils savent qu'en
marketing pour aller chercher un plus
grand audience qui va leur faire les
agents ces 600 maîtrise le pauvre et
leur camp comme super castet partons
donc pour ton nom de l'abonné avec bref
si ça m'avait vraiment déçu mais j'avais
aussi un cours justement sur comment
faire des sauveteurs
puis 10e menton comment contribuer
toupie dit que c'est important la
personne avec qui on misait comme quoi
que souvent quand la personne est poche
s'est déconcentré fait maintenant sept
enfants c'est pas pour ça que j'ai
pomérols fassiez moteur et qu'ensemble
déconcentrer les gens
je pense que c'est bon tu essaies de
jouer
des fois il ya des gens qui tuent par un
gage et le pochât mans des fois quand
j'étais vraiment gros solution et je
connais un genre d'acteur qui chez nous
et tantôt que avait coûté mais pas de
casse avec catherine brunet louis puis
les skis tu parlais tantôt justement le
fait d'un acteur mais d'avoir des
abonnés est une personnalité ça s après
des déceptions on ne parlait dj le elle
est rousse aux mecs comme toi incident
déplorable mettant un mets toi est-ce
que tu juges
utilisez des trucs lotus et senna barkat
daoud facof aussi qu'on commence même à
la base si c'est moi j'aime instagram
dans ce sens que j'ai toujours aimé
prendre des photos et puis moi j'aime
organiser une jambe et photos pour les
quelques jeunes et an prochain
jean ravon un espèce de thèmes stress en
plus tout seul phone c'est quand j'ai
rien à faire je prends le métro j'aime
ça comme et 10 urgences
c'est toujours quelque chose qui j'ai
trouvé le fun mais c'est ce que j'ai
jamais dit quelqu'un qui au regard des
monts en harmoniques qui a essayé
d'avoir le plus d'harmonie possible qui
vaut comme cg interac aucune gêne
interac pas beaucoup avec mon auditoire
comment ne pas leur photo titia on dit
et répète que je te réponds dans leur
commentaire pitié au récit de coop des
jeux genre je peux influençant le p
comme je fais un peu de publicité sur le
morceau parce que parce que je comme un
aimant tank avoir l'opportunité
pourquoi pas si je le vois que j'ai en
tant qu'acteur ça se pourrait que je
fasse une pub à la télé fait pourquoi
pas le faire sont mes réseaux sociaux
jaillit une pense que je le fais un peu
plus comme quand je venais de découvrir
ceux là maintenant je commence en fait
j'avais beaucoup moins dit j'essaie
d'être vraiment plus picchi sur ce que
je fais j'ai de plus en plus mais c'est
comme mehdi tank avoir l'opportunité
pourquoi pas aussi un restaurant moi
j'adore aller retour en enfance chez
beaucoup j'adore aller au resto avec moi
le reste on m'écrit pinzi elle tiendrait
de celui-ci jean menu veine coupe de
story
et oui jouit j'aurai la possibilité de
payer mon repos comme tout le monde mais
en même temps j com pourquoi pas aussi
une offre un beau super à une bouteille
de vin la totale baisser ce type ça va
être bon depuis comme en même temps ça
me permet aussi souvent il ya l'aide des
amis puisque je fais c'est souvent j'ai
vu de mes amis qui sont dans ma vie
personnelle qui justement ont pas accès
à ces activités le ou à se payer des
reposes même effet que je dise invite
pis à leurs fins de repas gratuits
ça leur fait comme ça nous fait une
belle soirée d'amis fait que comme
pourquoi pas fixé sur que d'un côté
comme un françois parce que je
l'utilisent et j'utilisais fait que j'ai
des abonnés puis on fait aussi de la
promo tiges cependant l'aïe dans la
jambe et gagne dessus qui sont comme qui
bachelot sans compter qu'on soit parce
que je le fais un peu aussi piger je
l'admets mais mon point à tavaux j'avais
un point au bowling mais oui mais c'est
ce que je fais pas pour ça je vais
jamais comme mon but voit jamais
d'augmenter dans mes abonnés si je perds
5000 abonnés demain matin je m'en
contrefous tu comprends pas ce que parce
que je sais que mon métier c'est pas
d'interférence up ma vie ne dépend
aucunement de ça j'en profite vu que si
accessible pour moi mais c'est vraiment
pas mon but premier
mais c'est sûr que j'aime le fait que
justement je peux aussi utiliser le fait
d'avoir beaucoup d'abonnés pour
transmettre des messages pour je le fais
pas beaucoup parce que honnêtement les
fois que je les fais si je suis jamais
quelqu'un qui va être contente si je
pense que j'ai fait un pause mais c'est
une plongée mais jamais ou vrai j'avais
fait un pause parce que m
justement un communiqué pas vraiment
quelqu'un qui parle beaucoup à me ton de
changement climatique si j'y suis pas
tant pour parler de ce même si je
pourrais je devrais peut-être juste
parce que je suis pas si cultivé sur les
sujets généralement py qui pas envie de
comme un piquet sur un des bonnes dans
lequel je me connais pas sans que tu es
en ce moment il ya beaucoup de filles
qui font des trucs sur le body pas été
vilipendé commun il ya tellement de
filles qui se prononce dessus je vais
être une voix parmi tant d'autres puis
je vais ramener le même message que tout
le monde des jeunes aimant les filles
qui font juste parlé et c'est beau c'est
un beau mouvement maintenant l'enfant de
parler trop des fois trop c'est comme
pas assez
c'est comme on a compris
fake je n'ai pas fait jusqu'à donc
amener quelqu'un commandes sur ma photo
que la raison que j'ai beaucoup de rôles
jeux parce que j'étais grosse genre que
je quittais pas dans liszt en dehors de
deux filles américaines qui devraient
vraiment commencé à perdre du poids que
ça paraissait dans les dernières années
j'en avais pris je t'apprends faut que
je me faisais commenté gère directement
thé avec cette fois là j'avais comme
publiquement fait un message que j'avais
dit comme quelqu'un m'avait ou un site
j'avais juste j'avais répondu jean rex
is not my story apprécié j'avais comme
fait d'hystérie pour expliquer que que
je trouve ça plate qu'il ya encore des
gens qui se cachent dans les médias
sociaux pour intimider les gens puisque
comme on devrait tous accepté puis que
oui j'ai mis des faux mais comme
j'essaie de puiser maxity bref puis même
si j'essaie de comme parler de ce j'ai
quand même des gens qui viennent au
marché sont comme sont comme suit pas de
la tension ne serait pas faire ce qui y
était comme elle savait que genre
l'anorexie les personnes quittent
anorexique pour être cool
jégo mais si tu m as pas le propos non
messagerie jamais j'ai rangé
j'ai comme juste utiliser mon anorexie
pis les gens vont utiliser le mot
anorexie pour come back chips comme
réglée j'ai dû remettre un espèce de
story pour dire comme en passant jessica
le rexy c'est une maladie mentale je
n'ai su entraîner que les anorexiques
c'est des mauvaises personnes d comme
peu importe ce que tu dis souhaite faire
bâcher fini c'est juste que je trouve
platique même si j'essayais d'utiliser
mes réseaux sociaux pour
oui si oui si c'est à la mode petit une
bonne mode le fait qu on en trouve des
causes qui les défend c'est pas un
devoir essentiel pied dans la vie il
faut choisir des combos et autres tout
ce cruel ces actrices qui devrait mettre
tes énergie python temps là dedans parce
que si tu commences à défendre des
causes argumenté que les gens sur
internet ça va devenir cet avis et la
cabane il faut juste faire un choix
le fait le choix de dates activistes
pour des hospices
[Musique]
une autre question peut-être une
dernière question avant qu'on compte
laisse partir d'un même dans même
thématique on en parlait hier justement
il scarlett johansson qui fait une
entrevue cette semaine sur atwan ce qui
est un show est ce qu'ils mangent les
ailes de poulet épicé plus ça va plus
les ailes de poulet sont épices les
graphes ainsi comme est mangeable
puis elle a look une présence sur
internet alors qu'un mais des métiers
sociaux elle a le port instagram repos
facebook puis hier ce qu'on se demandait
où yahoo ont été les acteurs slash
actrices de cette génération là qu'ils
ont eu
qui ont ils sont devenus connus qui sont
devenus reconnu en fait dans l'air ou
est-ce qu'ils n'avaient pas les médias
sociaux eux vont avoir eux mêmes s'ils
décident de ne pas jouer la game
instagram ils vont avoir encore des
rôles pour la fin de leur carrière
ces autres changeront rien est ce que tu
pense qu'en 2019
1 à une actrice soit un acteur qui veut
percer peut le faire avec
aucune présence sur les médias sociaux
est une question je pense que je pense
que oui je pense que c'est juste plus
difficile je pense qu'il faut encore
plus que des marques
oui exactement puis ils partent à
présent sa meute on soit d tox
en entrevue sur les tapis rouges il faut
vraiment soit juste vraiment bon puis je
pense aussi que de la même façon les
gens qui mise seulement sur instagram
pour devenir comédien
bonsoir des personnes passé il a mené
amener les gens vont se rend compte
qu'ils sont pas bon si ça va ça va durer
un certain moment le fait que comme de
beaucoup d'abonnés petit point mais
difficile en ce moment les kings aussi
qu il ya tellement des civières mettons
sur netflix qui sortent d'édifier mes
moutons et de bovins ou un mouton m2 qui
things 6 il 6 films d'amour prévisible
cheesy d'ado puis c'est vraiment des
films d'ados puis ça va tellement pogny
que du jour au lendemain
j'entendais sur cette file par les sept
fils est passé de comme 500 abonnés à un
million d'abonnés tout avoine encore un
peu comme le bénin soit ministre insee
est talentueuse depuis ce jour au
lendemain à cause des soeurs il connut
un rail poteau doit fait qui tourne dans
toute mais souvent c'est que ça rit avec
des acteurs qui sont pas nécessairement
ronge et je me dois de look et ses
symboles psicom mais reste que si c'est
rare que tu vois ses acteurs le vont
finir dans les grands films des meutes
osaka funyo panier mais c'est l'allié
russe à faire un rôle qui vraiment
intéressant qui va sortir bientôt sur
ted bundy lh2 hubert maetz erreur ces
gens là qui vont finir parce qu'un
maniche donc il était juste ça va pas
amener loin fait que je pense qu'il faut
quand même une partie table je pense que
c'était extrêmement talentueux
tu vas te démarquer dans des rôles puis
en même temps tester des suivra tout
il inclut un réel des castes ou un
producteur de casse pas parce que tu as
passé d'amener où tu dises aussi que tu
as envie de tourner coeur real qui est
6e ces valeurs que c'est ce qu'ils
veulent c'est qui qui cherchent pas
réellement un talent qui cherche
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup d'abonnés non
fake mais je pensais passer quand même
à talent égal à temps un garde dans les
galets ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle est les
castings directeur prend la personne est
bizarre j'ai l'impression j'ai
l'impression de simcoe je me trompe que
dans un marché comme au québec ça doit
jouer dans balance beaucoup
moi je trouve que je suis au contraire
je trouve que dans un marché au québec
justement je trouve qu'on regarde pas
tant le nombre d'abonnements trouve que
je te demande québec on y va vraiment
plus pour qui s'est le plus démarqué en
salle d'audition
c'est ce qu'on va tout en avoir et c'est
comme l'équipe du moment à septembre
1800 ouais mais tu es si ceux ci sont
sentant client qui est capable de tirer
trois cent mille personnes d'entrée de
jeu
au québec c'est considérable comme que
des coups de main mais chaud qu'on a
quand même un peu plus une diversité
show qu'on va pas tout le temps les
mêmes acteurs et même rôle c'est vrai
que visiblement cause qu'elle ait eu
comme skype la cause des fugueuses et
sûrement cas précis fait offrir beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup direction oui aux
essais mais moi aussi après monsieur
lazhar si je me souhaite offrir beaucoup
d'affaires mais reste comme je vais t il
ya quand même une diversité que je peux
jouer dans tout ça on va pas tous vos
frais parce que justement ce thème un
peu tiqué comme si je me mettais à jouer
dans tous les gens seraient que
justement on caste plus au québec les
gens pour leur talent plus que pour
leurs abonnés parce que on fait
justement plus des films indépendants
ces serrures confère film qu'on est
comme notre but c'est que ça sera notre
quartier on fait plus des films j'ai
l'impression le pipec que je me trompe
ou si j'me je me connais pas 100% mais
je ne le fais plus justement pour l'or
l'or pour lacourt qui ont fait des films
à gros budget qui vont pas nier si on
n'aime pas beaucoup le dd des
blockbusters de moins de gaza attend
aussi des défauts absolument faire tu en
profites ce nom lui rendre ou parce que
c'est de l'argent
public ces [ __ ] sa une aux
subventions ouais c'est parce que dans
le marché du québec c'est quasiment
impossible par un ex pour ça qu'ils se
croient dans l'équation m tandis qu'aux
states et sujet de l'argent privé puis
foot fassent plonger d'un quai au québec
où si même quand beaucoup d'abonnés pacy
- je n'aime pas ça que moins on ne
remonte pas autant nos films sur
l'éthique c'est vrai c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que c'est rare les acteurs
sur instagram que je suis qui disait
allez voir si comme justement c'est que
j'ai connu ce dilemme l'un peu en
faisant un mon dernier film de requins
et les trois filles avec qui je tourne
et une des finances fonce pour un autre
truc c'était comme à la fête un autre
tournage mais c'est justement ça m'avait
choqué qu'un médecin des contractuels
dans son contre deux films avec a promis
fallait promouvoir
après la série elle avait tant de postes
à faire sur la série qui est beaucoup
d'abonnés ce serait vraiment non me met
vraiment en fait mais l'idée autres
ayant à peu près un million d'abonnés
sur leurs réseaux sociaux puis justement
comme ça mais oui ils vont vraiment la
rencontre vont vraiment le faire c'est
comme promouvant le film sortait jean
lady comme quand sa soeur janet de la rt
blessures parce que nous on ne l'est
jamais t'en fais piges
j'avais pas trop quoi faire parce qu'en
même temps ils faisaient tout puis
j'avais envie d'en parler piste est fier
même temps je comme si m c'est comme on
fait pas penser au québec fait que je
voulais pas avoir l'air de la fille qui
comme un but soi même qui comme moi
jorge torres nilo je veux les barreaux
la 2cv casse des mois sur le plateau ici
se dit je l'aimé tant
quelqu'un s'est même dit segment mettons
d'entrevue connais comme à gaffory cinq
minutes même se fige les nippes jeter
comme passe est trop fine l'on me et
jusqu'à moi je trouve québec j'ai comme
je me sentais un peu mal j'étais comme
l'air de tellement comme la croix moins
de temps en temps le monde détruit une
façon de promo son film c'est qu'il ya
une grosse différence en faire la pub
shampoing puis faire le plus profond à
peu pourtant fait mais personne car
féroce si afin d'être apte pour son
geste il devrait donc ça passe mieux
mais c'est vrai je pense que aux etats
unis c'est plus un truc utilisé
d'utiliser les réseaux sociaux comme
milieu de la publicité fait que je pense
que pour ramener entendu à talent égal
je pense que c'est plus aux états unis
justement qui la personne que le plus
d'abonnés que je dise exemple il ya un
film hostile s'appelle de floride a
project je pense que c'est quoi ce genre
de films indépendants ou si dans le fond
le personnage principal est une actrice
sur instagram
le real lui faut d'entrevue qui trouvait
pas le casse parfait puis avec comme
référence cette file dit je me suis
trouvé une actrice comme lt que son look
comme un peu sa nature doit prendre les
chercher a cherché à chercher n'écoute
d'un casque juste pas elle qui est
finalement sa marche à fond
c'est ce que mon frère dans le même
ordre d'idées il ya castellan nadeau
dans les faux tatouages c'est pour un
petit rôle parce qu'il s'est dit autant
d'abonnés ça va faire deux pas du tout
ils voulaient telus programme ayem se
travaille et que des noms acteurs parce
que
il ya quelque chose qui plafonne dans
certains cas qui l'avait justement le
naturel du rôle qu'ils avaient besoin
ça marche à fond et lisant des super
bonne dans son film pour le rôle qu un
fait et c'est fake fin qui s'est dans
certains cas des foyers des
personnalités qui s'est pas
nécessairement la bonite attire mais
c'est juste le fait que ces personnels
est quelque chose de spécial qui dans le
film ça marche
merci beaucoup de gens là vraiment nous
eûmes et j'ai une amie j'ai un ami qui
écoute ton émission charlotte ont amusé
à l'oa fils parce que c'est ce qui dans
le métro mais en ce moment là entraîné
comme l'écouter jusqu'au couple infime à
12h jamais tu passes pilsen au travail
est fait merci à philippe merci à tout
le monde qu'ils nous écoutent aussi
maille messling bien sûr
[Musique]